So what causes watery slaw?
Well, it turns out, that the problem starts with the cabbage itself.
Vegetables are mostly water.
The cabbage is no exception.
In fact, this head of green cabbage is about 93% water.
All that water helps make cabbage crisp and crunchy, which is a good thing.
But it's, also, water from the cabbage, that
ends up diluting the dressing in our sad bowl of coleslaw.
It makes such a bland mess.
This is where salt can help.
The salt slowly diffuses into the vegetable,
but also drawing moisture out.
When salt is applied to any vegetable, including cabbage,
it creates a higher ion concentration at the surface,
than exists deep within the cells.
To equalize the concentration levels, the water within the cells
is drawn out through the permeable cell walls.
This process is called osmosis
So the concept of osmosis is very similar to diffusion in a lot of ways,
And it builds on random walks just like diffusion does.
And so, just as we have talked about how if you have calcium ions or water
ions in one part of a solution, they will kind of naturally wander about
and spread out through the solution.
The same concept kind of applies here, except the difference
is that in a lot of biological materials and cell walls, there are membranes.
And they're usually semipermeable as we say.
And semipermeable means that water can diffuse through naturally, whereas,
other molecules cannot.
And usually, large molecules cannot diffuse through,
or a very charged molecule, such as ions, cannot diffuse through.
So here is just a line indicating a cell wall.
You can imagine that this is the cell wall of the cabbage.
This cell has water in the inside, and on the outside,
he's going to add salt to the water.
So the water molecules are going to move around randomly,
and they're going to be crossing the membrane in both directions.
But when they find themselves on the side of the membrane that
has a higher salt concentration, they're going
to have a higher probability of staying there.
And so you're going to have an increase of water flux towards the side
of the higher salt concentration.
What I'll do is simply toss my shredded cabbage
with salt. Set it in this colander over this bowl.
So the salt will pull the moisture out of the cabbage,
and this setup makes sure that the liquid drains away.
Because we salted the cabbage and carrot ahead of time,
we no longer have to worry about watery coleslaw ever again.